man fragt sich natürlich wie und wann
hat sich der präsident angesteckt ja und
da gibt es vor allem eine veranstaltung
die als infektionsquelle gilt ja das ist
wir sehen gerade die bilder die
vorstellung der kandidaten für den
supreme court von donald trump er hat ja
das glück während seiner amtszeit jetzt
zum dritten mal einen neuen supreme
court richter aufstellen und dann auch
wählen zu lassen und wir sehen das an
den bildern der einzige pluspunkt ist
dass diese veranstaltung im freien im
garten des weißen hauses stattgefunden
hat aber ansonsten wurden jegliche
corona schutzregeln die wir so kennen
die haarigen abstand alltags maske
wurden vernachlässigt man sieht hier auf
dem bild auch in der ersten reihe sitzt
donald trumps frau die first lady
melania trump hinter ihr sitzt
die sprecherin des präsidenten die
inzwischen auch positiv auf corona
getestet wurde also man geht davon aus
dass dieses event durchaus so dazu
beigetragen hat dass es im umfeld von
donald trump im weißen haus jetzt
wirklich massiv möglicherweise zu
positiv testungen kommen wird und genau
das ist jetzt auch die grundlage dafür
dass in washington im grunde genommen
gerade massenhaft getestet wird also es
werden jetzt alle mitarbeiter des weißen
hauses getestet man will da jetzt
wirklich sicherstellen dass man auf
jeden fall all diejenigen die
möglicherweise sich infiziert haben
könnten in den letzten tagen sofort aus
dem verkehr gezogen werden in quarantäne
kommen also es gibt massenhaft und herz
wenn ich da kurz einen haken darf wer
kann das sein man weiß schon von einigen
die sich angesteckt haben oder es gibt
im engsten umfeld von donald trump viele
infizierte eben seine ehemalige
sprecherin topix eine seiner engsten
beraterinnen die von der sich
wahrscheinlich so geht man jetzt davon
aus donald trump auch infiziert hat hier
auch das bild noch mal genau genau dass
es noch mal die veranstaltung und immer
mal genau die waage halten
also man sieht hinten rechts auf dem
bild sitzt melania trump in der ersten
reihe hinter ihr die ehemalige
sprecherin von donald trump kelly ann
conway
und diese beiden wissen wir jetzt stand
heute sind auch positiv also es ist noch
nicht von all den wie viele senatoren
sieht man in der in der reihe auf der
linken seite also das ist jetzt die
grosse sorge also dieses bild ist
eigentlich so sinnbildlich für das drama
das sich jetzt so in und um washington
herum ereignet denn man hat jetzt
natürlich die sorge dass ganz der zeit
dass der ganze regierungsapparat
lahmgelegt sein könnte weißes haus
inklusive aller mitarbeiter der kongress
wir haben hier gerade senatoren gesehen
es gab auch diverse veranstaltungen im
kongress im senat farina hier auch
nochmal weil wir haben eine grafik
nämlich wo wir genau sehen wer jetzt
positiv getestet wurde
die sehen wir gleich diese grafik genau
hier sehen wir auch noch mal die namen
also kannst du uns auch noch mal kurz
dazu sagen wer ist jetzt hier wer genau
also das first couple sozusagen der
präsident und seine frau natürlich topix
ist eben seine enge beraterin die schon
vor kramp symptome aufgewiesen hat also
von der er sich vermutlich angesteckt
hat es gibt gerüchte dass das weiße haus
über ihre symptome bescheid wusste und
dennoch anfangs noch versucht hat das zu
verheimlichen auf der anderen seite hat
man sie auch auf einem rückflug von
einer wahlkampfveranstaltung bereits in
der air force one in quarantäne gesteckt
also sie hat sozusagen abgesondert von
allen anderen passagieren dann diesen
flug beschritten und hat damals auch auf
dem rückflug eine maske getragen das ist
beobachtern
gefallen reportern die da bei dieser
wahlkampfveranstaltung dabei waren und
dann eben auch beobachtet haben wie der
ganze tross die air force one bestieg da
ist aufgefallen dass hope hicks eben
plötzlich eine maske trug was ganz
ungewöhnlich für sie ist denn im weißen
haus herchen herrscht zwar die regel
dass regelmäßige teste wird dafür wird
aber eben darauf verzichtet maske zu
tragen und hob iks hat ebenso selten wie
auch der präsident maske getragen und
jetzt schauen wir direkt auf die zweite
grafik wir haben nämlich noch eine mit
den negativ getesteten im umfeld hier
sehen wir auch noch mal die namen genau
also ganz wichtig im mittelpunkt
natürlich steht der vize präsident mike
pence
der im zweifel übernehmen müsste sollte
der präsident jetzt wirklich an eine
beatmungsmaschine müssen und nicht so
wie aktuell geplant die
regierungsgeschäfte einfach von seinem
krankenhaus ried weiter übernehmen
auch in seinem engsten familien umfeld
in trance engsten familien umfeld um
tochter ivanka sieht man hier und der
ihren mann jared kushner sind die tests
negativ und die große sorge war
natürlich als gestern die nachricht
rauskam das tram positiv ist oh mein
gott hoffentlich hat er nicht seinen
demokratischen herausforderer joe biden
angesteckt zum glück waren die beiden
bei der debatte die vor ein paar tagen
stattgefunden hat mittwochnacht
deutscher zeit dienstag auf mittwoch
zum glück hatten die da einen groß genug
also der sicherheitsabstand zwischen den
beiden war groß genug sie haben sich
auch nicht die hände gegeben das waren
die regel neben für diese corona debatte
aber natürlich ist es ein geschlossener
raum und da war die erste sorge
natürlich hat er möglicherweise auch
sein herausforderer angesteckt das ist
jetzt erst mal also es gab durchatmen
dass joe biden
nach seinem test verkünden konnte erst
mal negativ aber natürlich bleibt da
eine gewisse spannung weil man die
nächsten tage sicherlich noch mal testen
muss und sehen muss wie sich das
entwickelt und ob er möglicherweise
infiziert ist nur der test noch nicht
anschlägt